miquel et on revient maintenant sur ce
débat qui a tenu ses promesses et qui
vous a passionné vous étiez très
nombreux à le suivre
le face à face s'est vite transformé en
duel et malgré quelques convergences ce
sont bien deux projets distincts qui ont
été proposées arnaud gut est clos et le
compte lorsqu'il arrive elle est déjà là
20h50 les deux candidats se présentent
souriant sur le plateau c'est encore le
calme avant l'affrontement un débat
historique attendu véritable duel projet
contre projet sur les questions
économiques et sociales nicolas sarkozy
et ségolène royal ont marqué leurs
divergences premier exemple les 35
heures qu'est ce que vous allez modifier
dans les 35 heures pour qu'on comprenne
bien les partenaires sociaux en
discuterons et se mettront d'accord et
discuteront branche par branche et s'il
n'y a pas d'accord il n'y aura pas de
nouvelle loi
les 35 heures n'ont pas créé d'emploi et
les 35 heures ont été responsables
d'autre chose de plus grave encore c'est
la rigueur salariale qui fait que nos
salaires sont trop bas
vous savez ce que les gens ont fait du
temps libéré après les 35 heures qui
d'ailleurs contrairement ce que vous
avez dit en créer plus d'un million
d'emplois
les gens se sont pour 70% d'entre eux
mieux occuper de leurs familles
autre désaccord marqué sept fois par une
passe d'armes
la fonction publique d'abord je n'ai pas
dit que j'augmente ray le nombre de
fonctionnaires j'ai dit que je
maintenais leur nombre mais que je
redéployer le nombre de fonctionnaires
en les retirant là où il n'était plus
nécessaire au lieu de recruter des
douaniers gérés par des infirmières mais
non c'est pas possible maintenant mais
je suis normalement ce n'est pas parce
que la fonction publique hospitalière
s'est payé par un autre budget que le
budget de l'état le recruter a plaisanté
à temps parce que vous pensez vous lirez
l'assurance maladie non polluants par
des prix entre les collectivités
territoriales et l'état vous pouvez pas
redéployer entre l'état et l'assurance
maladie
voulez vous accéderez ces normes éditées
et bien moi je le pourrai ah bon elle
veut augmenter les bas salaires lui
préfère détaxer les heures
supplémentaires réduire le train de vie
de l'état
le nouveau thème nouvelles
confrontations les retraites
les lois fillon ça consistait à passer à
40 années dans un premier temps 41 dans
un deuxième temps de cotisation l'idée
de françois fillon qui étude était juste
et puisqu'on va vivre plus longtemps
il faut cotiser plus longtemps pour
payer les retraites ça me semble un 6 1
non ça dépend de la pénibilité du
travail je suis désolé bénédicte
maintient l'écart d'espérance de vie
tels que je viens de vous les non c'est
très injuste non après 2h42 débat tous
les thèmes n'ont pas été abordés et
parmi les sujets oubliés la défense
nationale ou les banlieues pour les
prochaines élections présidentielles
je crois qu'il faudrait se mettre
d'accord à l'avance pour qu'il y ait
deux rencontres de débats comme dans la
plupart des démocraties 1 à 2 au minimum
et ainsi on pourrait traiter tous les
sujets nicolas sarkozy a trouvé son
adversaire agressive mais estime sa
mission accomplie des heureux que je
fais pas jusqu'à que c'était un débat de
qualité
je n'ai pas eu de problème particulier
durant ce départ paris s'est passé comme
oui ça
secret de fabrication
je crois déjà que l'expansion pour
comparer un certain nombre de choses ça
c'est important
dimanche soir l'ultime face à face se
fera cette fois dans les urnes au moment
du vote